ready guys welcome to another fantastic
episode of punch-drunk sports it's your
buddy the team and I'm here with fight
mommy who's having a bad just found out
you were pregnant I just thought you
were putting on pounds but you're
actually yeah I was like maybe she's
drinking a lot of beer I don't know yet
countdown is what 10 days 12 days I
think it's a little column a little cone
we're supposed to die early but like
they're supposed to sell you up after
and you know she might get cut out of me
there's a lot of us are you're gonna get
the extra stitch isn't that what they
say sex hurts for the rest of my life oh
good you should get the whole thing
stitch shut yeah just like sneak an
spackle the outside and you know drywall
it and just nothing nobody's none the
wiser Jonny's here Ari's always of
course on skype Aaron's in a fantastic
mood he's already told us to [__] off a
couple times in his own kind way and
joining us is our good friend for the
week it's Sabo right yeah but say thank
you thank you
sure oh and you are from is it babe
exhales what is pronounce right you got
it thank you and it looks like an
incredible science project I'm gonna get
incredibly stoned on the show and this
is gonna be funny Ari has it decided to
join me he also has one in New York is
this correct
yeah grinding grinding pot I hope and
that's I'm fourteen-year-old that's
under your desk
oh yes well there it is whoo-hoo sure as
heck not tell us a little bit about this
it really looks like like you're brought
to perform surgery you're probably gonna
see stuff like this when you give birth
it just looks like something a doctor
would wring out it does really it is
yeah that really would be like a great
way to like get the baby started with
like a vaporizer right right out of the
cave babes out the gates thanks that's a
game yeah just like you don't want to
[__] up his lungs guys we're all
about safety for children here so make
sure you have your babies baby instead
of smoking flour it's just a better way
to go yes definitely listen to our Ian
to answer your question we just try to
create a vaporizer that
would really fulfilled the wants and
needs of a hardcore cannabis consumer
but someone that also wanted to be
healthy most of the vaporizers on the
market
most people say they'll use them for
convenience or to better their health
but it's rarely their favorite way of
consuming cannabis usually they'll say
smoking or dabbing gives them a stronger
effect so what we wanted to do was kind
of merge the two worlds together give
someone extremely clean pure tasty vapor
but at the same time make it really
thick so that they get that really you
know nice punch in their chest like they
get from smoking so that way you could
you know enjoy your cannabis at the
highest level while not impacting your
health negatively right almost like I
said negative not that you were saying
uh naked ly I'm like wow this is gonna
be a real interesting show we're gonna
get kicked off YouTube again but this
time we made big wheat State in
Washington State so while you were a
rage Mariner was that yeah I was still
learning English when I first came to
America but once I got down to Cali
that's when I started picking up the
cannabis no were you from actually
ironically I am born in Japan but just
flew down from San Francisco today right
you been up there for how long
actually I moved to America when I was
one years old and to San Francisco so
for the last 40 years okay that's not
that bad huh yeah not that bad Ari saw
English second language as well yeah I
was gonna say Hebrew they're part with
their condiments I know all right got
the end we're looking at all his cabinet
spices a human yet cumin ketchup any
bomb essential what's that can you ask
that again okay so you don't need any
water in that bottom chamber that's
actually like a reservoir in case you
overfill so you just need water up until
that little line stupid
call yourself a STONER you've been doing
it wrong the whole time re take what
back he always gives us this angle so we
can see his three shitty trophies that
he's won in his life this act the fourth
time on this show he's like I'm just
gonna stare him under my trophies or
second place in a spelling bee but it's
spelling has one L in it best comic
worst player is the way he got in the
comedy basketball leagues 2011 well
that's you really held on a kiss he
kisses it puts it back above his condom
in and pot cupboard yeah you don't want
water in that you [__] idiot
beautiful I will say quick unlike unlike
the volcano it gets going pretty fast
which is like the biggest problem the
vaporizer where it's like I want to
smoke right now and so a lot of
vaporizing take like 10 minutes to warm
up and this one does not which is way
better like by the time do you start it
up and the bite time you grind [__] put
it in there it's ready to go right which
is good that's cool a lot of apes don't
they take a long time I'm not a big babe
and not to have anything against Apes I
just don't vape a lot so that a lot of
them take like a long time to heat up
yeah takes like way too long
[__] them okay no yeah wait that's not
your product is it no it's not our
product the volcano and actually the
volcano was the kind of standard before
our device came out and what we really
wanted to do was to make sure that you
know I consume cannabis the traditional
way as well and I thought that the
volcano while it is a great machine you
put all the vapor into a bag and most
people don't smoke out of a bag so I
wanted to bring something that was more
familiar to even one sleeping one yet
but I wonder I wanted to just bring a
form factor that was a bit more familiar
to the cannabis connoisseur so we have a
long element to it and allows you to
take what I like to say technically
thick milky rips yeah that's what got
her in trouble in the first place
ethic milky rips nixing you know she's
putting on the old elby's make sure
she's nailing her vagina ship so [__]
[__] yeah we got it all right when I
think that was implied everybody knew
exactly what we were talking about just
gonna say oh are you a edibles guy I am
an edible Devils [__] me up too much
make me so nauseous
especially back in the day like I never
knew what I was getting into you know
right before pot got legal out here well
you you know before you can get licenses
and there was that movement for it we
would always do all these pot shows to
you know support to support all that and
I was in Comedy Store in San Diego La
Jolla and I go in the green room smoking
joints outside with everybody I'm kind
of stone but I'm going up first so I'm
kind of like I got to chill out I go
into green room and there's all kinds of
food from Don Carlos taco shop and so he
like just like filled the green room
with food I'm like [__] yeah and I'm the
only one in there I murder a couple
tacos and there's all these cookies
big-ass cookies I eat a whole one and
this big guy comes in and he goes oh
cool man you found my edibles don't eat
more than half of one of those though
and I've got a second half going in so
I've already had one and a half Oh what
oh I know like Oh cookies a phone out of
my mouth I'm like I just ate a whole one
he's like oh do you but when somebody
makes an edible and then tells you
you're [__] yeah you know I mean
you're like oh no and I did good with I
look like Bobby Lee when I was on stage
that's how Asian I was just completely
and all I could do is tell that story
and then they laughed at it but then I'd
be like repeating jokes in the 20
minutes said I'm like wait did I already
talked about this all right you already
going for it
Ari's going for it let's go for it
all right let's go for it too so it's
fairly easy to use I'm just gonna load
the first one I'm gonna show you how I
use it first and then I'll let you go
next right oh that work it's like a sex
toy and I'm in I'm not saying I'm not in
beautiful so um I don't know if you've
ever done yoga but I always tell people
just do a long yogic inhale on that
that's how you get it really nice thick
and milky so long
he's breathing at everybody yeah well
enamored with this device
alright you have the exact same one it
looks like I don't have that like tube
there jeez [__] together bro and then
you pull it off okay alright I'll send
you one Ari alright Teebs let me load
you a fresh one so you get all the nice
turbo licious flavor how do you know
what that word means but it sounds good
turbo licious uh it just means it's a
flavonoids that are in the plant it's
smooth that's the thing it's a smooth
high you don't [__] up your throat okay
my first doctor told me I should use the
faith and actually um because we've
spent so much time focusing on the
cleanliness and purity of the delivery
of the cannabinoids we've actually met
quite a few athletes uh both retired and
active athletes that utilize this not
just for recovery but we like to say the
word activation which is not medication
or intoxication but activation is when
you're in the zone and flow state and
you're able to be the best version of
yourself while you're competing now I
understand you're a big MMA fan is that
true Oh huge MMA fan well that's the
fight mommy right here she loves it
oh yes yeah dude I used to and I smoked
before it would slow everything down to
where it's like oh they're going for an
underhook okay so my options are I could
go try to swim or I could do that yeah I
think I'll swim and then like it would
just slow everything down so much you
just see it coming
even in basketball you're like alright
somebody stole me a bounce pass when
that bounce pass arrives to me my
options are either drive to the basket
pass it back I can take a shot where's a
defender going okay here's the pass
there and then you kept it it's like
took like three minutes to get [__]
catch a pass yeah you described it
really oh [__] are you playing
basketball with a bunch of
four-year-olds wait slows it down and
actually interestingly enough we're
hosting the Kenneth leet sub-only Jiu
Jitsu tournament this Saturday and
Sunday at Santa Monica Pier the athletes
are allowed sub only so like tenth
planet Eddie Bravo
just submission oh no sorry I remember I
forgot you're a comedian Oh barely
barely today but yeah in the jiu-jitsu
community obviously consuming cannabis
and rolling is is extremely popular so
we thought you know let's bring it out
of the closet let's actually have a
competition where the athletes are going
to consume cannabis before competing and
we got a couple world champions coming
out to showcase themselves as well
that's awesome so that's all weekend at
Santa Monica Pier just Saturday and
Sunday for the 420 games so al
harrington's Center hosts a
three-on-three basketball tournament
Frank Shamrock and bas Rutten are going
to come out and do the arm wrestling
contest and the 420 games is a 4.2 mile
run on the Santa Monica Pier and the
last year a ultra marathon and run it
won it and we'll see who wins it this
year dude I'm gonna go to that that's
cool yeah and he'll do that in like
three and a half hours they should make
it so they test your tolerance find out
what it is and then triple your regular
dose wait an hour and then say okay go
out and fight like edibles if you
normally do like thirty do like how can
we're doing 90 today is somebody in
somebody's guard for three hours get up
he's just in guard for three hours I
slowed it down for me it really slowed
me down play whatever song you want on
the loudspeaker to really [__] over your
opponent it's so if you're like start
playing some like war pigs it just be
grateful dad yeah they're about to get
you in they're like dude this is [__]
rat I got a what you're in guard for
like three hours and then someone puts
on get up stand up a Bob Marley and it
reminds you to get up and stand up stand
up for you right I went to a phony funny
story speaking in concert so I went to I
couldn't go to Sam sing because my
sister and I got tickets to see the
avett brothers at Santa Barbara ball
before [__] incredible stay we're
[__] phenomenal they were so good and
yeah it lets a little bit more and so I
go to get a like classic like they start
a song right like one of the songs like
oh I don't like that this is
I don't like Senate go to pee right when
I'm blooming my dicks in my hand then
they start one of the two songs I wanted
he and I'm like mother Fox of course so
then I don't have like enough time to
race to my seat so I just kind of stand
on the side and watch it and smoking a
cigarette when watching it and there's
just two girls over there about my age
they're nice and they're telling me
they're such big fans of mine I said
have you seen the documentary on HBO
that Judd Apatow did about him and they
said no she goes I'm saving it I'm
saving it for after the concert I'm
gonna watch it and I go oh girl it'll
knock your tits off if you're a big fan
and then they both look at me and her
other friend goes she just had a double
mastectomy so the only thing I could do
is I just go so then you've seen it then
they were laughing I'm like girl what
idiot I had no clue and they're like oh
no it's totally fine but what are the
odds that you would say that I'm like
that's not even a phrase that I usually
took it okay Oh took him fine especially
when I said that that really broke the
ice when I was like oh so then you've
seen it but what are the odds of that I
was like oh god you I mean I felt like
one bad I feel like I shrank three
inches when she said it off she really
could have been super offended by that I
mean even if she did it you know she
could have tagged her so she could have
hashtag me now did she keep her nipples
do you know that's an option you can
keep on you can give her no she gave me
one of them mastectomy where it's like
it's terrible what are you even allowed
to bring up like you have a we have tits
flatty before or were they nice like do
you miss them what are we miss is it
give you an excuse to not have bad tips
yeah do you get when you go to a
restaurant order flapjacks
yes yeah I'm glad you didn't go to the
concert with me
so I miss Sam sting but I heard it was
great it was when I got back I got back
at like 11:30 12:00 went to the comedy
store and everybody there had just come
from it and everybody everybody was
saying Sam absolutely killed it to
special' yeah was torched
pretty proud of all she was here but
like he had a bunch of new stuff you've
seen Sam before you know albums is all
new stuff and I understand he throws you
under the bus which I'm a huge fan of
spells your first one last Belzer nope
no no no apparently spells your first
and last name while he's talking about
your ugly dick Ari's never called anyone
out in a special though I'd be a
hypocrite to have a problem no [__] yeah
that is tasty thank you that is a good
president what is it turbo delicious
terpene so terpenes are what was the
word you said Oh turbo licious her
poetry polishes isn't that where you
went to college with you the turbulence
yeah
you paid uh women's basketball I believe
now were you stoned then and were you
like wow she's passing me this ball it's
coming at me really slow
hey and posted up by a five foot eight
lesbian hey Ari
you regret Tebow they never posted me up
not to five foot eight ones sorry I'm
fine once they were on the blocks and
I've eaten up on the [__] wing block
share the shots using my height to my
advantage and your penis and your
testosterone and probably your age just
full one people would post me up that's
a five put any people I'll take it when
it's there not one it's not that do you
regret Marilyn leaving the ACC so much I
don't know mistake right people on the
teams are I don't know too [__] rude
against terrible northwestern Michigan
State I don't give a [__] huge mistake
on I always kind of rooted for those
teams yeah and I gotta hate them and
then and then Georgia Tech means nothing
yeah you lose rivalries and you don't
have new ones yet you like a good fight
you know it's a rivalry going on [__]
fight yeah bunch of fans for the sake of
some money do back in the day well since
it is both Pistons when I was growing up
in Chicago area and like dad lamb beer
and they're always like close line
somebody the reason they got Charles
Oakley was because of lamb beer they're
like we need someone to protect Jordan
and just like your job is to knock the
[__] out of somebody that doesn't really
exist anymore in the NBA yeah no thing
our test was like the last guy right
I mean there's what's-his-face up in a
landfill oh what's his face Greymon
yeah my greens do you remember the video
of Larry Bird getting pushed over and
then jumping up punching yeah he just
stood up it's like no [__] this and you
start punching like right away when he
got knocked over by the [__] I think
the Pistons and it's just like it's all
man it's when people discuss a fight all
the time when people get suspended well
you got thrown out that game when people
disagree as to ball times and the goats
and the Jordans and LeBron arguments
come in no one ever mentions bird it's
because he's white is that really what
it is
could be yep are you totally frozen look
how high re is he can't even move
Podcast is going so slow do you think a
guy like do you think Larry Bird you
could drop in in two days and I and I
would be just as good yeah absolutely I
just wonder if he gets enough lift to I
I think maybe if people could guard him
a little better today I mean what six
seven and an outside shooter and a great
passer I mean he played he played this
kind of ball back then you know the kind
of ball you see the Warriors playing and
all this [__] it was quicker [__] it
wasn't his crafty that late career he
had a little late career success though
and I watch you watch those Clips when
he was old man is back was back he was
like spa shoes back was bad not even
jumping he would lay on the ground
because he couldn't sit in his chair
when he was out of the game he would
just lay on the ground yeah I mean do
you think it he could get away with that
only person ever be a Finals MVP season
MVP coach of the year GM of the year
think about that him and the year what a
mistake that was bet they wish they can
have that one back mm-hmm
I mean that terrible GM really in
hindsight
in hindsight re how high are you right
now I loved when you were frozen like
that you can't be a great player and a
good manager of talent I don't think cuz
you expect you really too hard on the
guys and like Jordan you know well
Jordan sucked at it Isaiah Thomas Isaiah
Thomas sucked at everything yeah except
playing basketball I was hated in when
you put in kiss Magic Johnson or he
wouldn't not kiss somebody was like
turned on him when he had AIDS I was
like yeah yeah yeah and he's been way
more successful than [__] Isaiah uh
re have you seen the Garry Shandling
special on HBO yet that Apatow did no
but I actually got to talk to up it's
how the night before it aired and he was
like that's think uh that's my I was
like oh did you do that he was yeah then
we just started talking much handling
and how you know my memories of him and
his life pretty incredibly some geeks we
saw that [__] tall nerd just watching
him laughing and he's like yeah it was
just a no Maj to him because he like oh
yes you're talking about Bill on Freaks
and Geeks here that's right it's pretty
great it's wonderful yeah yeah it ends
the first one ends right when Larry
Sanders shows and it's what two hours
the whole thing's four hours four hours
yeah to two hours so last night and then
the new one airs tonight are really good
really well done but essentially he kept
every journal and joke book that he ever
had in this like little bench thing but
I'm like 25 yeah until death so him and
Apatow were just going through him and
you know doing a documentary about it
you know but when he was still alive and
then he died before they finished it but
it's I mean if you could go through all
your old notebooks I mean really
personal stuff he was right talking
about what a [__] mitts he is yeah Wow
yeah absolutely there's so many great
store stories he's like mitts he's such
a [__] [__] I'm sick of her yeah you
know it's really um and it's like sweet
it's sweet you know a lot of a lot of
his fears and a lot of like yes she said
he was you know she kept on him he was a
writer and not a performer and that
that's why so much they kept [__]
saying like I took sharing forever to it
so chillin forever and I was like yeah
alright whatever I'm not gonna be [__]
Garry Shandling was it happy back then
right it was just such a different era
of comedy you know at one point in time
he was talking about you know spoiler
alert I guess oh by the way he dies so
Garry Shandling but he was talking about
how he felt that all of these comics
were just writing five-minute sets to
try to be on Carson
so no one really really was like doing a
lot of time and really working on that
trying to develop into like a longer
form comic ever and I was like you know
what I thought I felt the same way about
the Rose battles like everybody in the
last like four or five years and I'm
just talking about these younger kids
you know all they can do is roast and
they're great at roasting but then you
see them do stand up and if they're not
doing roast you know it's like you got
to bring the person with you to do that
joke you know I mean at a different club
and I was kind of commit and I was
tailed all those like younger people I'm
like dudes right non roast jokes you
know we're hard at work this week or
something one of the good ones out here
in New York and it's like it's like it's
great learn that skill and you can use
those [__] short jokes for the rest
of your standup but then get back to
stand up right that's just what this is
one facet of it you know now work on
your longer form things now work on your
act outs now working on whatever it's
always so backward I like because I'm
can tell I'm getting snow now uh that
like we know what like this looks like
we're looking at you
what's that I bet it was the pot you
smoked
[__] you know what I think our is
onto something it's like look naturally
we should look at you this way
but I feel like I'm a talking to you
like when I look at you this way you're
not even looking at me you're looking at
the back of my head but I'm looking into
your gorgeous blues over there yeah yeah
like another one right here so we've
been talking like small look at so I
highly recommend watching that Shandling
thing it's the first two hours were
great and then I can't wait for the
session if you have any interest in cod
I don't know if you have any interest in
doing comedy or if you are a big comedy
fan it is like a history lesson of the
70s and 80s and especially in particular
the comedy store they'll interview
absolutely everybody from Jim Carrey of
everybody and just kind of talk about
Shandling and all of his exes I'll sing
him it would be weird like if you died
and then there was like a movie like
this about you
like if everybody that dies they have to
have a movie like this about you I don't
think
laughs she did Silverman Garry Shandling
yeah um well she was on the Garry
Shandling show but if she did I haven't
gotten to that part yet I feel like a
lot of people I think he was already
with Lynda who sat by the time by the
time okay they hit the woman he was with
for most of his life it's in the
document the chick from Larry Sanders
show the hot one you're talking about
leo Larry Sanders yeah yeah I also
forgot how funny the Garry Shandling
show was oh yeah sorry
he always was ahead of his time of
knowing styles of television shows
absolutely that yeah that whole style
for that no one was doing [__] like that
back then and now every show sounds like
that every show seems like you know from
30 rock - all those that's all that same
style of behind-the-scenes even Larry
David all that [__]
yeah links to the camera sure like that
but like not so overbearing like like he
did this thing is like oh I gotta go to
Santa Monica for the next scene usually
takes about 45 minutes to drive in
traffic unless you can walk right
through the Christmas trees deep that's
in the movie or in the dock
yeah yeah that was funny oh by the way
we got to call this episode of apes out
the gates are you gonna need a to on the
plug what do you got going on yeah I got
Australia coming up Albany in Syracuse
and April 4th and 5th but Australia
Perth Melbourne Adelaide Brisbane Sydney
so you're going to every city in
Australia there's only like nine cities
when did you get here a kid I know I
feel like you're gonna fall off the
chair oh I'm fine no all right last
night at the end of the show I got a
promote - oh I want to promote something
real quick for our good buddy here at
all things comedy Bret and Bill come is
going to I want everybody to go vote and
especially everything especially
everybody that [__] on Sam if you [__]
on Sam on Twitter just last week your
price your price for doing that should
you have to
and vote for our good buddy Brenton hang
on let me tap and load this what's doing
gets too open for sleep Esparza and
where is it app it'll come oh yeah okay
so the Kevin and bean foolishness they
they'll be the opening act at the
Microsoft thing so go to can I tell you
something about that show yeah it's
amazing it's super big they make it so
they just book a bunch of comics that
are usually other show the crowd is
[__] juiced and it's one of the shows
that threw me over The Comedy Central
came to see me there at that show in
front of like 6,000 people and they were
like oh oh this guy's alright
right it's a good show yeah it's a
really good show so to be you Tiana boy
you got a vote you got a vote for him
and then he'll be the one who'll get in
so go to okay ro q dot radio.com k-rock
KROQ radio.com slash blogs slash Kevin I
believe that's all there is right is
that it yep
if you guys go to Kevin and bean comm
it'll redirect you right to that page
okay yeah the first thing so you do that
go to Kevin being calm and then right
there on that page then we're all tweet
it during the show right after the show
up Johnny blast on the punch wrong thing
I'm I just retweeted it from awesome
yeah so help our buddy out very funny
comic and does all the social media here
and at the store you're pretty much
never an out on the Internet
you're number two thanks Sam everywhere
I go he's there I think there's more
than one bill come hey I'm in Troy
Conrad who would you say is on the
internet more him or Sam Sam okay at
least I'm working backer so all right
what website you want to give I'm gonna
make sure that this vape works I think
he said he was saving it for the end
where do you vote for about this webpage
he said scroll past the video sorry
will tell us the videos yeah that's what
that's what Brendan yeah and then
there's a dude in a red flannel shirt
you just click on that that image oh
yeah well the guy who's [__]
headshots on there it's got a way better
chance yep
yeah that's why we good that's why we
got a vote that's why we've got a Oh
HEC it up yeah I think Bill burr tweeted
it right
that's dope you're gonna win and just
based on the people that [__] on Sam if
they all vote you probably will be the
headliner rough week first [__] that
guy whose headshot it is is not even in
the contest so we're okay
yeah he's previous winner but oh yeah
well he's gonna win again still he's
gonna get a lot of write-in vote he's
not even yeah he's hearing a lot of
don't okay yep there you go and alright
tweet form to would you you can do it on
Arabs with every device you own go to an
Apple store vote on all those devices
I'm just saying yeah I don't vote for
president I just voted for you I voted
for president I in a red state okay
bingo that is handled uh what about this
the tournament is great
absolutely now the Dukes out it's the
best tournament are you my only thing
that I don't like basic oh that's good
lost we would have guaranteed at least a
million C to the final if Michigan and
Loyola who I'm pulling for yeah I mean
what Michigan is the other team I would
like to see win yeah they have to play
each other I'm like god dammit know what
I would love that to be the finals if
that was the finals I'd be so stoked I
think they look a win I think Villanova
is probably gonna win you know this old
lady this 98 year old uh none they keep
showing whatever here's what I want to
happen I want Loyola to get in just for
this woman because ninety eight years
he's been there and then I want it to be
go to a last-second shot and Loyola's
down by two and when the ball is in the
air she dies before she sees him like
all right all right there and they got a
camera on her and she just croaks and
then terranes it drains the three but
there she is dead in her wheelchair
that's like Hank Gathers I Felicia yeah
Hank Gathers
it's been an amazing story for them and
you know what here's what's interesting
when they she's an unrest she's a nun
and she is the just some sort of other
job who cares other than being a nun but
she's just always been a super fan of
the team she like emails I'm kind of job
can't even walk what I mean I figure she
does something there but she's pretty
rad but I'm getting sick of her because
that is the kind of story that gets
overproduced in sport that whenever
there's something like this going on day
everybody's got an interviewer and they
got to show this I mean you know I get
it
they're setting up when they lose so
you're invested in this chick and then
you just see her crying on the sidelines
walk out solitaire to you and with a
team like that they need something yeah
we remember the Holocaust get her out of
here she was supposed to be a 1 a 1 game
story and they turned her into the sweet
success another the final sport it's
ridiculous they got but they didn't
expect to have this much there's no
story here let's move on to our [__]
granddaughter who just graduated from
[__] her granted law a grant her
granddaughter is probably 70 what you
done lived and looked awful she looks
awful guys I don't care what her age she
looks awful for it yeah she sold a lot
of scarves I bet she's 98 years old
holy [__] yeah just move we've been
saying don't look at they pass the bill
yet you're telling me shows what's going
on because they cuz they trained in how
to put your hand up tall black I come by
I tell you this I don't know if there's
any bets that you can make about her but
you can't make bets on this tournament
so as always go to our friends bet DSi
use the could punch 25 years ago use the
code punch 25 they get you 25 bucks
and I believe they're still doing it you
know whatever you put in they'll double
so if you put in a hundred bucks now you
got 225 bucks so that's pretty sweet and
now is a great time to bet on this
tournament coming up this weekend you
can parlay all three polyp doody parlay
all three of those yeah it's just that
small get it all right tournament yeah
but you could easily do yeah okay let me
ask you a question though can bet CSI
start putting actual bets on stuff like
we're saying in this podcast like will
she die before the end of the season I
don't know I mean I guess it depends
maybe on what they are they think it's
fair on them but people just standard
like you know tend to want if you get it
we could do better a month
better than month or something it has to
be something that we cannot fix that
really is just chance outcomes we say
something like that
[__] it throw it up because yeah I mean
there are way like I could think I'm
gonna way around that people like I
thought of 10 grand on the fact that she
dies and then I [__] dumped cold
water spend $4,000 to have her killed
$50 that's not worth killing somebody
alright just scary I just cry when she
like wheels out of the bathroom then she
just has a heart attack she has to be
easy to scare plus she's like oh I was
asked Jesus and pray to God cuz you you
know had to help us win and it's like if
you were such a good nun wouldn't you
guys want a championship by now 100
years ago begging God for them to win
you haven't done it yet so God must not
like her baby baby don't pay harder
crazy smarter yeah
race race martyr that might be C vapes
out the gates is a good title for the
show but play smarter is pretty damn
good too I may have to do a coin toss on
that Pittsburgh hired Jeff capable from
Duke by the way that's uh big news there
he's there oh yeah lead recruiter yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if you see a few
defections to Pittsburgh he's a guy I
think has been dropping bags for
sous-chefs key to get all these
returning classes yeah Jeff capable used
to play for Duke he's uh yeah yeah big
yeah Pittsburgh just hired miss airhead
coach I have a vague question this dial
right here that's just how hot it is or
whatever yes correct
why is it only like cunnin in the medium
it's not like all they get smokey all
right if you get it hotter oh yeah
absolutely there is above 392 degrees
benzene is released benzene is
carcinogenic so we have a lady who's
about to give birth so I thought we
would keep it below 392 you're pregnant
what a gentleman you're pregnant
what the [__] this shit's great yeah
that's interesting man see you really
know all that like the science and like
minutiae of it I'm dumb when it comes to
that stuff I'm just like oh is that a
joint I'll smoke that know you're
pregnant at a great time because people
are I would think less likely to touch
your belly right now have you gotten a
lot of belly touching other people why
because of the hash tag thing Yeah right
see before this year I think people were
getting that [__] all the time people
just watch strangers walk I'm like oh
yeah hash tag me too for to god there's
another good title well focus on this I
know right it's so funny I'm excited for
this right I'm gonna go I think
Michigan's gonna win I do I got Nova I
think they'll know what I'm saying I'm
saying with each fall between the two of
them I think it's gonna be Michigan
Villanova and I think bill Nova wins by
seven yeah
Kansas could win though I think
whichever team comes out of that side of
the brackets gonna win I think Michigan
could be Kansas better than Villanova
yeah I think they have a better chance
yeah but don't fill in oh it just looks
unstoppable what are you looking at I'm
amazed your socks match your shirt it's
like it's like I smoked weed and I just
realized I'm wearing a onesie it's
actually a three Z which is everything
just to like this pan through the shirt
tucked in and you pull your socks over
your pants that's what I bought three
z3z feel free it is really cold outside
so it's a good thing you have your foot
easel it's not cold out today but it has
been cold lately yeah so that's my picks
on that you are a dog in the fight
I mean you got to go Villanova but I
would root for in inverse order of their
seats so I would root for Loyola first
then Michigan up and then Kansas at then
no no but although no but just haven't
been good in a while but like they've
been really good this year
I like that kid another Lenovo they want
to add was in the NBA perhaps
oh yeah was that his name I'm sorry what
who's a kid from Villanova whose dad is
in the NBA
like they he's their best player he's
like when the best players in country
like oh rocks I like that kid and I
watch like one of those like you know
produced little sport segments just
about him I'm like a little four-minute
thing and his dad was like I mean pushed
him like a [__] and but that's
what he wanted it wasn't like a bad you
know bet like I'm not like levar ball no
no yeah but and he was like dude and
then when we're playing them like he's
in high school and I remember the first
time that he beep did he ever beat me
and he was mad and he was like cussing
at me it's the first time you ever
cursed at me I was like wow that was
interesting and dude he's incredible
he's by a top five pick yeah for sure
Sam would know more than I do about that
but as he's the basketball guy ah what
do you guys think about Ferguson could
be I made two bets last night not I bet
yes I blessed you oh but no no because
they're just like side bets with buddies
Oh
Tate I guess that's all right take lunch
with lunch with tip what loser buys
winner buys lunch or loser buys lunch
and then a good joint like one that's in
like the plastic thing you don't mean
not like roll some shitty [__] Pinner
like a good [__] like a solid joint
you bought it from that chick on wheat
with my buddy Jeff and I got could be in
both they both think Ferguson is going
to get them I got to be hearts with
Ferguson heads with could be hearts with
Ferguson just because the BJJ aspect I
like the way he fights so I do train
that 10th planet as well so he is part
of the I mean I'm part of the 10th
planet team and I mean I think it's
gonna be a really hard fight but man
just seeing how once khabib takes people
down
his control his ground-and-pound its I
mean my wife who watches kind of just
she'll come around and watch like the
big fights with me but you know khabib
was the only fighter that she saw that I
didn't tell anything about to her
initially and she was like this guy
seems to be on another level so when
even a novice like her could see the
difference I'm like its heat doesn't
stop coming forward I mean he walked
through leg kicks he walked through body
kicks like it didn't even affect him
when he fought uh Llosa
yeah yep yep and that guy can kick I
mean he was walking through body kicks
that would at least back up 99% of the
fighters yeah and I think he kept moving
forward I mean you saw my buzz to be
like he looks surprised like Jesus good
this guy won't stop coming at me who do
you want to win between rows and rows
you want I want rows
yeah I just like to watch what looks
like because if if I don't wear my
glasses and if I'm far away from the TV
it looks like a girl's beating up Tony
Hinchcliffe and it really is fun to
watch it really is fun to watch
al oh I bet lunch on with Tony last
night and I have rose on that yeah
because he's like Joey yeah he was he
was yapping about her and I'm like you
don't know I think Rosa might get her
again and he's like how much would you
like to have ads I go how about loser
kills himself
no limelight as a belt holder I brought
that up the other day like what do you
mean disappeared you're right yeah like
like Misha got like her shine when she
won the belt like Holly but where has
her personality's nice bigger no one
liked me better she just had yeah she
was almost backwards those like she
because she was on the reality show
where she cried every I felt like we're
surprising everybody I can't stay she's
very emotional very emotional I really
think it's her personality that's the
reason I died fine I find her to be to
have a personnel well no I just don't
think it's big enough
she's not like self-promoter thank you
yeah I don't know like what kind of like
PR team she has or anything like that
because you're a right Miesha Tate
Rousey of course but a lot of these when
they get them
all of a sudden there yeah there are you
on talk shows and there and there
yeah maybe I want to she needs attention
though maybe she doesn't want to do that
although I follow you on Instagram and
she's been doing a ton of sit-ups I am
pretty sure she's gonna she got good
course treat her doing sit-ups on her
and every day she's doing like weird
situps like aside and get the leg up you
know must be all this [__] used to hate
and jam and pee she's doing that every
day so right right right my money's on
you I don't know just don't know all
right just don't sit ups what about you
you might Tony to win annoying
and what about you in this one you know
I first fight I was a big you wanna fan
I still am a big you want a fan but Rose
actually won me over in the interview
afterwards I love that I know I didn't
at all yeah I I just rose hater and my
wife is taken aback yeah [__] tears in
the Octagon say good name for this
episode what are we gonna do guys I just
don't know I I think kabhi wins that
fight
I think Ferguson can get him I was
talking we were talking his last night
and Ferguson from his back can fall can
do damage I'm talking about those elbows
memory who did he [__] up really if
somebody [__] up from the from his
back with elbows and I mean I wouldn't
count him out I don't know if he wants
to say [__] he wants us to go to the
ground I think his best way win and this
is striking he's definitely the lesser
of when it comes to Jets of the - yeah
it'll be wrestling and ground and pound
against the funk wrestling and Jets of a
Ferguson and Ferguson's Instagram is
also very interesting I mean I don't
know how it translates to fighting but
watching him through a metal bar it was
it was eye-opening you know I was just
thinking okay maybe I would change my
bet now I met this guy
The Comedy Store Saturday night and
Irish's [__] like the kind of Irish you
can't really understand what he's saying
it sounds like he's talking really
you're gonna be like slow down bro talk
a little talking slower and he wanted to
bum a cigarette and his were in he was
in the are and his were in there and
he's a God don't make me go back in now
to get him you know I got sure man fine
if I find no problem here and have one
turns out his he's a huge MMA fan and
his best best friend that he went to
screw up with went to school with is
McGregor's trainer so we're talking
about that and he basically said he
basically said that right after the
mayweather fight his buddy said to
Connor what's next
and he goes khabib in Moscow so if
khabib wins this please McGregor could
leave in Moscow Wow he would be nuts
insane and that is directly from
McGregor now will it ever happen who
knows but that's what McGregor
apparently said that he wanted and
that's breaking news Ari Shaffir okay he
would like if I could be he would fight
could be in Russia of course he will how
much money you know he must be a zillion
dollars they're gonna put so much [__]
they cheat so much you're gonna put
little things to hurt his performance in
his [__] water of the whole hotel
absolutely yeah I'm both gonna get
poisoned or something I'm like dude have
you seen Rocky don't do this because
though they're just good even those even
those people cheated the people who were
banned from the eliminate to play as are
another one up like curling they cheated
and curling love it she did everything
yeah I had to give it them man that's
right let's crank this up to like bad
bro party oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
like this is a story from yesterday that
Floyd Mayweather's 5050 to be in the
cage by the end of this year he I pray
to whatever that thing in the sky is
that that old lady prays do that
that happens well I saw Rogan say he
could maybe start with a guy like CM
Punk now do you think he would even have
a chance against someone like that CM
Punk
well no he'd be stupid too
I mean he'd be foolish to fight McGregor
they just be about money it's like don't
go beat me up try to like hit me too
much because they'd be down to it I the
only thing I can guess is that he is
spending all of his money because what
else is he doing what why is he doing
impossible yeah yeah you say that but
it's impossible he he can't spend all
that I mean an extra 300 million dollars
for some fun thing does it doesn't I
heard his legacy don't you think
I mean if he gets destroyed by something
no way does I see him Punk is anoying
going in right exactly you don't hurt
boxes let me see it's like oh this guy
yeah yeah yeah I think he could beat CM
Punk I just think he's a better a
striking I think he amongst us gonna
shoot on him well he's also trading with
tyron woodley I don't know how much that
means but [__] shoot Johnny look up
Tyrell Mosley right now he put on like
all this weight I saw I heard Rogan say
that he thought that if Mayweather did
train MMA that he should just focus on a
couple of basic holds you know like
submissions and then just focus like one
thing that he can do very well and get
very good at that profession of that
yeah I'm not an expert on movement or
anything like that but to my eyes as
well as other people that are movement
coaches there's just a way that CM Punk
moves that isn't like very dynamic very
fast very strong like if you see him
punch mitts there's no snap at the end
of his punches and I just think someone
like Floyd Mayweather who is at least a
plus athlete got [__] up by our boy
Mickey Gaul yeah exactly enjoy I think a
weather proof what does it prove to be
like oh here's a boxing guy fighting a
[__] wrestling guy this hasn't anyone
ever beiie nothing definite ever they
really now the UFC it's like so what
have you shown and you can also be the
[__]
a promotional tool you see any pictures
of Woodley I you know I searched uh
Taran Woodley ever wait and I don't see
anything
hello jack oh oh you mean he's Jack yeah
but I'm like 20 30 pounds there was some
article a bleacher report or something
that I saw and it was about him training
him but then you see Woodling is like
god damn won't you have to cut 30 pounds
notify or maybe he's not fighting
anymore
he looks big as [__] like he looks like
he would have to he would have to yeah
there so that's what next weekend is
that could be uh two days before my due
dates the night yeah it's April 7th
April 7th so that's Saturday begin yeah
a week was that a dope I know I want to
watch it but I don't want to ruin
anyone's time if I go into labor so
Hardy at my house I even like everybody
out just invite ya just in a fight your
ob/gyn make sure you invite you should
have it at the hospital if you're going
to labor we'll all like well I'll be
there and watch a fight actually be
really fun like cuz it would really keep
me distracted like on in the room if we
could pull up and have you a bunch of
comedians in the room just keep me yeah
just heckle joe said he would be my
doula I would really like that what is a
doula
sounds like a hat an Egyptian would wear
that pregnant Comedy Store waitress has
a doula and she's been trying to
convince me to get one but they're like
two thousand dollars and it's just
someone only coaches you through birth
I'm like I don't have that money
she's a dude what's that like a mid
second motivation I have a midwife but
like the Midwife is free it comes with
oh here's a good no yeah yeah midwife
crisis is a good band name
[Laughter]
I think this babes working but I would
let Sadie danto coaching me thoroughly
bread that'd be a nice evening
oh yeah he would use your voices yeah
well I'll just do it not just do
impressions all time you just like I'm
sick I don't mean you know that sounds
like [__] a doula a man if that
thing comes out with five arms man I'm
half the Oh was there I would be dying
that's a Dark Lord like laughing would
be messing I'm thinking
traction that's a dark arts homeboy my
uncle had a russet potato for an eyebrow
a woman who is trained to assist another
woman during childbirth and who may
provide support to the family after the
baby is born so it's like a midwife that
stays with you after work also known as
a birth companion sounds like it's
kidnapping and then they have the baby
it's a non-medical why would you want
somebody who has no medical training
said what are they that this is some
business [__] this is just [__]
the UH all right did you hear about dumb
[__] no Rams are going crazy
they sure is they're going for it it's
like their playoff team but they're just
like shaking it up down to consume now
and Aaron Donnell already was Defensive
Player of the Year and you got those two
next to each other now you know they're
in a luxurious position and you know
who's gonna be in this position soon as
the Cleveland Browns I'll tell you why
the Rams still have their running back
Tigerlily and the quarterback golf are
both still under their rookie contracts
now they're the two best players on the
team but they're still under rookie
contracts in three years and two years
respectively they're gonna have to drive
dump truck some money and keep these two
right now they're both like go a million
to a year they have a Super Bowl windows
what they call this so they have super
bowmen oh yes exactly
and so now they can spend all their
money on all these free agents they
can't they can only afford for two years
and go we're making our run right now
and people want to come here and play in
that new stadium here being Los Angeles
and playing that new stadium that's open
and soon but the Browns are about to do
that too in three or four years the
Browns are gonna be good they have
incredible receivers if they can figure
they're gonna have a rookie running back
and I order that quarterback I got to
figure out quarterback down and running
back yeah I mean you can figure if you
have it's not gonna [__] know but you
can figure that out through the draft I
think I mean they can but I'm saying
they have the first pick in the fourth
pick now they have the first pick in the
fourth pick I mean they they're yourself
running back in quarterback in in the
first 45 minutes of the draft which is
one month from yesterday I sure I trust
these guys drafting in a quarterback
honestly I mean a lot of quarterbacks
out there this year they'll pick the
wrong the one that is
a failure I have a feeling they'll pick
or they'll trait they'll find a way to
trade down and get two pigs and get the
wrong guy I don't know I just have no
faith and until they prove otherwise why
would you believe that they could do
anything like that I've heard they're
exactly honey remember once at least
yeah what do you say yeah I said I heard
they're gonna draft Tony Romo I could
see it I could see it so where tell
everybody where they can get this they
could get this we do because it works
let me tell you this if you can see me
and Ari right now yes yes I've turned
them both Asian on our website VAP
exhale calm that's va PE X H al e calm
we got a whole bunch of different glass
that they could choose from and each one
kind of gives the user a different user
experience so we like to say you can get
ones that give you more flavor or ones
that diffuse it to make the vapoury room
smoother and depending on the day of the
week you might choose one or the other
our website VAP exhale calm it's on that
little kuzey that's on your vaporizer
that you were just using and these are
all on there you also have a bunch of
glassware and all this sort of stuff
yeah yeah yeah and what is something
like this go for and comparatively in
like in to the market where does it you
know what I mean yeah okay so it is a
premium priced vaporizer it costs $450
we know it's not cheap so we offer a
30-day money-back guarantee as well one
of the things I like to point out is
that it uses about a third of the amount
of medicine to give you that level of
activation that you want so you're not
blowing through your reader exactly
exactly so our average customer within
three months it pays for itself and like
I said you know after a month if you
don't like it you know we take them all
back yeah it does that was one that I on
a nice mushroom trip I thought of that
that glass piece and it reminded me of a
kind of like a wu-tang style piece of
glass and so who do who like blows all
the glass who does all of that design
work and how does that all work yeah
most of the design we're gonna do that
one what's HAP
that's why he's here we're gonna have to
do that from now on you would our oh
nice okay well yeah yeah well just to
answer your question we got guys in Los
Angeles Austin as well as New Jersey
doing hourglass and most of the designs
are one of our employees or myself just
coming up with things that we like them
that we think are cool that's crazy man
blowing glass is insane yeah that is one
art that I'm not familiar with but I
love watching other people do it for
sure I was watching something like vice
news or something like that
and and they were talking they were
talking to guys that did exactly that
and do some of these things were like
now I'm not [__] you like 10 grand
20 grand
I mean they were just like a piece of
art you wouldn't even know you could
smoke out of it I know like yeah we
actually never probably probably never
will it's like it was like collecting
action figures just big these huge like
big glasses of like people blow you know
like blowing glass old-school I mean
they even got pieces that are fifty two
hundred thousand dollars and people are
smoking out of them and actually at the
last conference that we had in in Vegas
at the LA Convention Center but that's a
cool conference it's very for sure so
someone actually dropped the piece so
really sad moment for everyone that was
worth how much it was a hundred thousand
dollar piece it broke it was a guitar
and it would look like a tarantula and
yeah was it the guy who owned it who
broke it or someone else no it was
another company that was helping them
transport it so yeah there was I guess
the closest thing to you know go ask
blower beef that you could have was the
guy did you see the guy who owned it was
it was he there I didn't see but I read
about it on social media after I got
yeah oh you got to have insurance on
something like that right how do you
think yeah I would hope you would think
but still that doesn't bring it back no
but still that's like having like life
insurance like yeah you don't really
want to cash the money out just because
wife died a little bit better because
your wife fell down the stairs
you just had that abortion right yeah
yeah yeah quick give me a call oh yeah
okay oh yeah do we just weed out the
number uh-oh all right it will retweet
that right now mmm that's never good you
ever see when your phone is like oh you
have to wait when your phone says
something about a re we don't we haven't
had any bite the computer right let me
go I'll go over just you got it okay I
can answer you David go fingers on the
screen other numbers on the screen
yeah nice nice no I should be able to
see it mm-hmm so anybody yeah Colin talk
about whatever you want I'm excited for
the second half of this [__]
channelling thing me too I watched it
when I got home last night I watched
when I got home last night and then when
I got up today just restarted it
yeah well it's you know it's kind of
there's a lot of information in there
because they talk while they show the
diaries on the page yeah and you can
really miss a lot of stuff like I
noticed I did yeah first time I saw it I
missed a lot of stuff but I basically in
within 10 hours watched it twice as it
is two hours long did you get into Larry
Sanders at all I really like that when I
was in like college I watched oh
absolutely it's every now and then I'll
that's one of the few shows every now
and every couple years they finally put
it online I yeah yeah I'll go through
and blow through him again
I saw I do that mr. show also it's
another show yeah that's great every two
or three years I'll I'll get into a mr.
show [__] loop we're all watch like
you know a season and a half of them you
forget how wonderful a lot of those
sketches are what's that never get that
into mr. show Duncan loved him I give it
a real chance but it was always like I
think I just missed the boat when it
aired so there's no reminiscence for me
uh-huh
I loved it yeah I loved Larry Sanders
ready to get into that laughter I start
comedy I found out about that and then I
was like caught up it was like well this
was great yeah way ahead of his time
yeah you can see how everything kind of
did I mean so many Johnny some of these
shows borrowed from it you know like
ideas and setups and stuff like we were
saying earlier there's so many shows
that um
they did what they borrowed yeah I know
I was like I was in between Hebrew dude
yeah you know I was about to say stole
be brooding they really brew it that's
the now that finale of that show is
probably one of the best finales ever
that Larry Sanderson I where he has the
musical guests on and you know because
it's like house music I mean the balls
on that show to just have probably good
20% was just performers on the show like
it was a real show yeah like Clint Black
is on there when he was really funny on
that show yeah yeah he seems like a
funny guys he seems like a funny guy I
really like Californication did you
watch that with him on you love you love
that yeah it's a great show
yeah especially the first season yeah
you really so call in anybody if you
want to call in don't [__] on Sam yeah
no don't don't don't do that
it's furred so you too much anyway so I
maybe missed a couple shows but what's
going on with Sam yeah
oh he him and I got into a fight and
then he stormed off last step he wasn't
gonna do one of the bats that he lost
and then he just refused to do it
I also lost I also have to do it and he
just threw a temper tantrum and he was
like I'm not doing it he started making
up all these new rules and then left
when I wouldn't back down none of us
were like what you talking about man
right a bit and then even the kill
bosses or yeah that's the reverse
Kobayashi where you have to put a hot
dog in your butt instead of eating it
yeah you know textbooks like it sucks
but re did you really ever think he was
gonna do it yeah I believed it was a
human but maybe that was wrong yeah that
was a mistake I mean it's just like just
do it Sam just whatever suck it you guys
for themselves okay right cause another
storm of know what world where does it
go in what world does go any which way
other than like you're taking a bunch of
abuse on Twitter or
like are you doing it so just do it let
me just do it willingly I never want to
leave you alone and [__] call you a
winner
everybody's been pretty vicious from
what I've seen and he's probably seen a
lot more than I have he's he's probably
gotten a lot more than I've seen yeah
just you know
yeah that's what I mean yeah yeah yeah I
think any part of here's all that but
like what are you doing up you know pay
off any part of them go although this is
like a thousand people totally one thing
maybe I should let me hear it let me see
if you have a point at least should we
blame to you for rounding them up I even
said say whatever you want for your
opinion just tell us how you feel about
it and everybody was pretty clear I saw
one or two like almost saya but like you
know he does a lot for the podcast but
like one of those things is you know
Panther bats
the Yuri should go through the bank
sometime I mean do it on air goes up
well the other thing is that I know it
would words imprint April first it's
going up that's right
is that true wait a minute Ari hang on
we both know what's going on here that's
April Fool's Day oh I get it I get it
it will go up it's April 1st so it's
going up and how long after that can we
get a bag of bets widget on there well
the bag of bets are gonna be at the top
from the beginning and a little you'll
see another thing yes a weekend yeah
we'll go do it we will now be able to
keep track and the fans will be able to
keep track of what the bag of bets are
in but can we also on there can we have
everything that's actually in the bag of
bets listed we could do they know what's
all on in there yeah I mean I think I
think you got the right idea they're
going through a live show that's kind of
funny yeah because here's what I
remember I know we've done this before
because it's I oh it's me that we got
we're gonna have it's me that does it
sure grab it okay
and there's no way okay yeah we can
paper saying for that
I'll just could say we go through and
remove all the dumb ones because what I
was gonna say I know that I'm guilty of
this
writing them out and when we're going
through and adding new ones and then
saying something dumb like what about
killing yourself and then we'll all
laugh like kill yourself there's no way
you're gonna kill yourself and then you
lose the bet and and then hold you to it
I write it and I put it in the bag there
are things like even the reverse
Kobayashi when Tony was our guest on
that episode we were laughing about how
stupid it was we named it the reverse
Kobayashi we didn't name the episode
that and it's a bad one and then it went
in the [__] bag and then when it came
out
[__] eight nine months later we're
all like oh no [__] oh [__] I told you I
drew it out and just I just read
reversed Kobayashi and I was like ah
damn it before I read like I think I
know what this the oh yeah but then you
can tell you get to yapping about it and
I'm chiming in with jokes and Tripoli's
not gonna back down so we've kind of
kind of like soft agree to do it
and then I'm just saying there are
things in there that we may want to
discuss about being like okay hang on
I'm not gonna [__] like it is the
jizz rag forward forward is the jizz rag
still in there probably that's a tough
that's a rough one [__] it's really
that's I mean the next time I go along
got to wear that puke there because I'm
sure Ari's jizz has gotten like way more
contaminated you have to wear a pube
beard yeah I've gotta just wait
ari you told me that was [__] what
happened you told me that you paid that
off if it's a pube it IW did not pay off
okay why do you have to wear a beard
made out of pubic hair for Louis naming
all the sports teams yeah they're
brought Boston brontosauruses oh yeah
yeah yeah so use that bet right yeah
that think so so now you have to go in
there and wear that or they do make sure
that well I don't I don't remember what
the bet was a fan is it who brought it
up to me and then yeah I listen to it it
was like okay I think so
okay alright I'll check it out whose
pubes so I told them your own pubes at
least
oh they're cubes oh yeah that's the word
well you did that to you bro you did
that to you
yes so when when Sam's back
we'll do that we'll go through it and
then pull out all the [__] complete
nonsense [__] but we should also add you
know like have people add it's like hash
tag bag abouts like you always do and
then add us in the tweet like if you
have good ideas those Twitter ideas are
usually pretty like you know slice up a
finger I mean one out of ten of them is
good though
yeah you know some people sometimes do
have good ones oh yeah for sure for sure
they've had some good ones yeah by oh
sure but yeah a lot of times you know
like you have to block up to Rogen and
slap them without even saying oh are you
crazy
careers over but to your Leifheit worst
day your life I think if Sam did that's
a Rogen if you like I think he would put
him to sleep a key yeah like I think I
mean he would just punch you what I mean
you watch his goddamn instagrams
oh god this [__] man guy I mean the
guys like you know it's got pads on it
[__] but [__] he was working this guy
up his kicks get a switch kick that was
just like you're like yeah damn he's
he's um he's built like a brick house -
he is a monster yeah he like a beast kid
that's like the exact kind of guy that
you don't want to [__] with you know how
he always does Sam's shows like how same
as the show tonight comedy camp
mm-hmm so there was this girl who like
came and they always come in cuz I would
sell the tickets they always come in
they're like I'm here for Brogan's did I
miss Rogan no so this lady came just for
Rogan she's like 52 is she's telling us
it's her first comedy show and like
she's gonna start doing stand-up and
Joe's her hero she'll be really funny I
was like very cool you never know
and then after his set he's leaving and
she runs up to him and she kisses him on
the mouth and runs out the door and I
saw the she
getting the Morgana the kissing bandit
me - hashtag me - yeah if he did nothing
he just like made that face you know
that big eye Rogan face like and he was
like yeah right yeah and then he just
kept walking cuz she like ran up after
his said her she never after that was a
man she live been chased down hangout
and beaten up and just people right
woman does it just walks right out
scot-free everybody giggles at the other
day that's girls suck my dick and then
look then she just left I'm are you
serious yeah like what was your name
ah yeah I was like all right a girl was
like after a show once there's a few
years ago but yeah I was like hey I
wanna suck your dick and then I was like
yeah okay and then we went like page
numbers and then like then she came over
the hotel room later and then she sucked
my dick and then like I think she was
like that was great what kind of girl
was that pretty cool situation but yeah
I can see how you guys are so lucky
girls just want to suck your dicks cuz
you're you think it's like an honor for
the yeah but sometimes I don't want that
so what are you saying
yeah and also depends on like who's
attached to that mouth yeah yeah I mean
it could be like it I don't have to take
your dick out oh no I do
[Laughter]
exactly right oh I forgot about our good
friends of sikhi guys I have to have the
C key cap on my phone and it is
absolutely the easiest way to shop for
tickets you can be anywhere it doesn't
matter where you are just pull out your
C key cap and it'll literally find you
and tell you all of the good concert
shows sporting events anything that's
around you i won
I'm wonder if they're cheeky could think
and get that things at the Santa Monica
Pier yeah that's probably on there
what's that it been called the 420 games
yeah we'll take a look and see if that's
on there but yeah baseball is coming
around around the corner now is the
perfect time to get tickets to opening
day which I believe is Thursday
yep Thursday it is so why not go to our
good friends so you get the app I mean
you can always go to the website if
you're just sitting at your computer and
the phones in the other room but why not
have it on your phone because then it'll
always know where you are and it can get
you going you get the most bang for your
buck see key grades every ticket based
on value so that helps you you know you
can find out if you're getting good
seats or if you're getting overpriced
seats so make seeking your go-to app for
all of that use the code punch drunk
[__] you I can see what's on the screen
this is great what do you mean I mean I
can see the [__] Sookie excite that oh
yeah yeah yeah exactly and sharing it
yeah great so now I can [__] join in
her movies yep so that's C key right
there and use code punch shrunk one
promo code one word just punch drunk one
word and that gets you 20 bucks off your
first seat geek purchase hey try to get
some twenty dollar baseball tickets and
that's free if that's your first one I
actually use this app all the time a lot
of times just to see what like we rent
as each and I were in st. Louis I pulled
it up to be like hey what's going on
around here anything cool surprised by a
sporting event like oh nobody goes Blue
Jays games doing this I'm on point
oh really 10 bucks ready yeah we almost
went to a hockey game and then he found
out he had to do somebody's podcast when
he was there and I'm like man I don't
feel like owning a hockey game alone but
I wouldn't even know that was going on I
just pulled up seeking him goods like
what's going on in st. Louis one mom
here and it told me yeah
they may come we worked that back in so
you just clip on trunks thank you to our
good friends at see geek and if you
don't have that app you're a dummy still
those callers um no maybe no maybe we're
not live re
maybe when you were peeing we got kicked
off a YouTube we're so live oh we're so
live
we're so live we're so live so you're
not what your nervousness level I'm only
nervous for labor so I try and not think
about it
you mean just the pain you're awake for
you have to be awake for it you're even
a [__] sock down no even if it's a
c-section you're awake
no I mean you're out of it the what's it
called I mean that the pain pills what
are they called that I'm a girl girl
yeah yeah I'm definitely doing that
that's a shot in your spine yeah yeah I
want to be numb from the waist down as
long as possible yeah I would imagine
yes maybe I think we have a call I feel
like women at high rape on neighbourhood
should carry epidurals with them just in
case they're getting raped
let me hold on let me just inject myself
but then you can't run for like hours so
then you're just gonna get raped over
and over Hey and you're also turning me
on Oh ladies and gentlemen we have a
caller today
I love out people hey you're on the air
with punch-drunk what's what's the word
turn your computer down can you hear
that tube yeah that's T what's up buddy
turn your computer down okay I've got I
try to call about 45 times oh really
well you're on you're on drum what's up
wait were you calling [__] it what's up
this is often
three-one-seven no computer [__] 603 170
Annapolis I love it hey can you hear
Aria so on yeah I can hear him a little
bit okay turn down your volume on your
thing stupid hey [__] you right
literally positive he posited are you
don't bucket why am I here twice then
maybe because you're a [__] idiot Jew
magic so I've been dangerous it's like 9
a.m. today I just want to preface myself
with that here we are
oh nice standard trunk sale so I've been
listeners with the baby
like mid-2014 ish i saw re-fired the fat
man I remember the two Mexicans toe it
hop lady touching dildo corn
yeah I'm talking about getting raped
loved it yeah good time like six
different Studios boy I'm thinking it
might be time to end the baguette beds
okay
what why because each time the same has
to pay off like a major bag of bed when
there's a pube beard or the [__] in a
funnel
the fart funnel yeah fart funnel he put
up a major [__] snake each time he
gets closer and closer to quitting I
keep blows out bigger and bigger but Sam
you did an amazing job of changing your
voice inside this time in like kind of
abuse like you guys are okay let me ask
you a question do you think there's any
personal responsibility after the fart
funnel after the puter beer putting up a
fight there's any personal
responsibility on the individual to say
no I am NOT taking a bets right now yes
I think there is I actually have to good
point and think about that re gonna be
honest I really like that
yeah always laugh that the yeah I mean
that I think there's a little element of
that of just like you know cuz Sam's
like you know pitching are they getting
rid of it whatever and I'm like you know
what you can just never ever take a bag
of bats before yes you know it's true
but I mean it's like it's a part of the
show man and he is like that's a third
of that the show yeah but he could be he
could be the third that he can be the
third that just is like I'm not doing it
we can still do it with guests and and
me and Ari you know that's a good point
like you know I've been offered back a
bath before and I go no I'm not that
sure when you put a bag of bets on that
was it oh I thought it was sure but I'm
not back at that sure right okay yeah
that's a good point yeah well the other
times I'll just like yeah I'll just like
I'll just like I'll be I'll feel loose
more like funky yeah Maggie bets up 50%
I mean you don't like yeah you could
also do a TiVo so I'm gonna take out all
the really
like the stuff and nobody I think it's a
combination of all of that sort of thing
yeah but it's like how do you how do you
guys agree on that you know it's like
you guys have already like do they keep
escalating at this point make that line
okay
solution we have a separate one for Sam
Betts or like twirling around three
times or singing I'm a little teacup wow
this vape thing's fantastic okay but I'm
just saying like you know it would suck
if you say like Sam leave over some you
know show this show is all three of us
you know it always has been it's gonna
be yeah if it comes down to it like you
should turn this kobe reversed kobayashi
into a [__] like grand finale thing
like it should be like I don't know yeah
fireworks going on the background the
pyrotechnics like hey he's not gonna do
it he isn't absolutely he's not gonna do
it though I mean he's absolutely not
gonna wanna miss and pause yeah well
then it's gonna take the [__] breath
of that you make a bet you guys need to
have some kind of played rather he said
he'd rather be known as a Welch yeah
then then then do that and that's hey
man I mean I couldn't believe he agreed
to it on the news what comes with that
though did you don't just get that cool
now I never hear hear about it again
we're going to hear about it the rest of
your life
well that's it's like I can respect that
if you just like hey man come on I mean
I made his bed I wish I didn't and then
it got to this and I just just [__]
no way I thought about it there's no way
I can do it I don't want to do it it's
just a problem with your Romanian people
a lot of Armenians around here Moe
welching [__] like are you I kind of
get what you're come from man like the
Jews of the people of experience
terrified the Jews are clearly superior
if we're if we're counting that wasn't a
genocide the Armenians did not have a
genocide
did the G right yeah
didn't happen where where where you're
right the music well we're in nap town
are you call it where you at
well I'm actually living in Pittsburgh
but I'm from like half an hour north
like Carmel yeah yeah yeah right on I'm
saying about my village is Rome Brown
region like you are buddy region rat
where hey baby
oh stop been nice yeah boy yeah the pole
into the Midwest does that mean it is a
colon in the mirror yeah it's up in
Subway's that's where no dance that's
where Notre Dame and that's a shitty
town I I don't like it so Irish oh it's
garbage
it's awful I never go there that's awful
well actually it is all full of
hunchbacks I'm in here the women yeah
that's it that's the place where hey so
Johnny yeah what's up dude hey dude go
for a nobody I think you're just a
little delay okay so Johnny uh what the
[__] is on man what the [__] are the
Panthers doing today seriously like are
you kidding me what they do I didn't
even see yet what are we talking about
here the in free agency he did a hang up
on us oh that's good
I was gonna do it on him yeah yeah
question yeah hanging you talking
that was a good legitimate Wow good idea
bad execution that was a good legitimate
punch-drunk call yeah I'll even give him
the collar of the day as he's our only
caller Sam would have been really happy
I'm sorry you missed that he was worried
about the calls I think and that the
first call totally on his side yeah yeah
yeah I mean no but that was a good
classic punch will call you know why cuz
he's a fan of the show and he's
listening to it a lot so you knew a lot
of the whole history about it
I mean well just yes understand those
calls won't stop after a week or two I
mean forever
he's worried though that if he does the
bet that he's gonna be the hot dog an
ass guy for forever you know I'm saying
and I won't all right well yeah but he's
not you he doesn't care about you the
show's people go like hey
I'm gonna get out of the wind tunnel
whatever we got a tornado on the phone
hi tornado what city you destroy hang
out I know I'm on yeah I'm on a
skateboard in a [__] hurricane I just
wanted to let you know I asked somebody
in a wind tunnel somebody went South
Bend where that guy was caught or where
his family was from that's a place where
when I was a little kid and my [__]
horrible father so my mother would take
me and I'd be like I don't even know six
seven six
I'll be in my pajamas and just go from
bar to bar to bar to try to find where
my dad was and then like send me send me
in to go see if your father go see if
your father's in there but here's the
funniest part the first part first bar
we went to he was there and he's like
you never saw me then I go back out and
that way I got a three or four other
bars but I knew he wasn't gonna be there
because he was in the first one the best
but I was wearing a3z same one you're
wearing today yes yeah yeah yeah yeah a
youth medium I hope that tornado calls
back it was a little loud but I was
interested to see what city he's
destroying make a real tornado caused us
oh yeah let's get to tornado on the
phone we got ten minutes left
what's up storm chaser let's go you're
on the air it's a lot better now
oh yeah that is a lot better what's up
where where you at what's up Johnny are
people I'm walking from Venice Beach to
Santa Monica I'm making my way to the
Legion of Kings Festival this week oh
nice oh that's not I appreciate all the
hard work I've been doing for that I
know I appreciate that re la wet code
festival I appreciate your promotion of
that oh thanks
actually uh why don't I just bring this
up as long as you brought it up
Oh what would you want to say about it
anything I was just saying that I was
walking there drinking
6 a.m. just wanted to hear your potion
about re well if you want if you want
any information there's a website you
can go to it's Ari Shaffir comm slash
skank fest if you're gonna Ari Shaffir
dot-com slash skank fest you can get all
the big scape my skank best needs from
your boy Ari Shaffir and not from anyone
else that's Ari Shaffir comm / skank
best wow
hi Bri I appreciate that Ari peep are
you gonna be there this tonight I'll be
at the store tonight buddy skank fastest
tonight alright alright brother I loved
it both people call in have been drunk
for drinking from like 6:00 a.m. to 2:00
a.m. at least the other night there was
these two girls at the store
one of them was so drunk you know
sticking around with Don then she comes
back in the next day yeah Eric told me
about her yeah which I saw a taping
aleni oh so then the second night which
was last night she was there drunk again
really - and wrecked very annoying drunk
like you wouldn't even [__] I wouldn't
try to hook up with her because she was
too annoying kind of drunk and then but
I heard when her and our other friend
were leaving she's like we got a call
new ver and then the drunk girl guys I
can't call an uber they cancelled my
account I bet they did
I was like oh I never factored in
somebody being so hammered more than
once that they delete your account yeah
or they're like yeah you're not allowed
in Huber's anymore you guys tip on uber
it depends now that they have that thing
where you can just hit it yeah
I do that total my driver he says nobody
tips people I know that Drive and they
say they get like maybe two tips a week
I always yeah I always do a dollar I
always thought you were supposed to yeah
yeah I mean and they made a great know
that you can they just hit it on the
thing but he said almost nobody tips
yeah yeah it's crazy I mean I guess
people don't really know oh I saw the
worst thing the other day I'm at
I'm somewhere watching a sports bar
somewhere watching the tournament you
know sitting there by myself and the
waitress somebody comes up from a table
of four and he goes hey how much and
they've been sitting there all day and
he goes how much does my iced tea and
she's like what and he goes I'm gonna
pay for my iced tea and she's like are
you is everybody paying separately he's
like no and then she was like it's like
a dollar seventy-five and he gave her a
dollar seventy-five after a [__]
sitting at that spot for three hours and
she looked at him like is this come on
are you wearing like a body camera am I
on some punks kind of [__] what the
[__] are you kidding me and it's just
like is everybody gonna be [__] do
you mean you guys been sitting here
eating [__] all day and you want to pay
for one [__] iced tea put it
cheap prick this is a pretty good town
for tipping no I think because most
people have had experience in the
service industry I would think yeah you
hear a lot of a lot of people one of the
waitresses at the store told me that she
works at some other place and she got
$1,000 tip damn how was it at the store
the people tip well typically there
yeah there's certain comics that will
come in there and always be very
generous you know the audience I mean
I'm in comics - the staff here Rogan
talked about to finish it and then they
try to do it you know people like to
comment so I talked about the waitresses
other friends and when they go like once
you like know about the store they like
right joycie ron white throwing hundreds
around just to the staff yeah which is
pretty you know people like do stuff
like that well clear this is crazy times
like there's people that have been like
remember not one crazy rich guy was
there yeah and the bag is yeah he's like
a [__] gazillionaire on a magazine
and was yeah life is like a mogul in
that and then he he was just paying with
like thousands of dollars for people to
do [__]
what do you mean like do [__] like what
I pull the chair out that kind of [__]
when you're on stage you
my dad is on stage and diamonds like
show you jus balls and I was like no way
and then some guy on the side was like
I'll give you [__] he's like will I
give him money if he does and swell guys
like him 39 cents and I was like it's
not quite enough and then the other guy
that guy was like I'll give her thousand
dollars did he pay you
yeah he paid me right now Wow yeah
you know [__] like that I'll have it
every now and like cat he just whipped
out and gave you ten hundred yeah dude
fire a thousand dollars I'd kill my I'm
sure you were so disappointed - I'm
sorry Paul both of them yeah I was not
worth it all three of them all right
what do you what do you got before we
wrap up here [__] my new skate fast
website orange secure comm slashed egg
first we can get all the information I
saw another not just a announcement
about where you can go and also I think
just give it up for the lowest almost
forgetting it started and and then
everyone fan wise for trusting me I'm
not Louis to bring you all the skank
fest news I always love the Shaffir
throw under the bus the smile you really
have a whole website for this oh wow
yeah
news about skank fest you gotta Ari
Shaffir Cobb / skank fest and nowhere
else
Ari's I'm the one Ari will you sponsor
punch-drunk
ok then everybody should go to check out
our new sponsor Ari Shaffir comm / skank
filmmaker but then that's where you can
get all of your news about skank fast
Ari we don't have any announcements I'm
afraid it says announcements coming soon
we gotta get some money on that already
Lewis denies it but I already do know
something that I'm gonna bring to you
guys after April 2nd he starts we're not
some of the lineup
you'll get more lineup only from me
you'll get that lineup and more is team
on it if you go there to their skank
that's website but you get that lineup
and more if you go to my website Steve
on it again
I think Teebs on it yes is that breaking
news breaking news
there's breaking news everybody
the copyright on this is fart analog who
is that re so your web do I see you are
so stupid
[Laughter]
what a [__] dumb [__]
breaking news go to Ari Shaffir calm
slash gang fast for all of your news
yes we'll be a part of assuming he can
go to New York I think we'll be a part
of scag Fest this year breaking news
with arrows Schaffer Aaron good luck
with the Cardinals this week who do you
open with the Mets I think Cubs are at
Florida at the Marlins at that stupid
[__] dumbass Stadium so stupid it
looks like a [__] 12 year old girl
but built that [__] thing there's
like rainbows and little dolphins
[__] swinging it's so so ugly and
they legally can't tear it down it looks
like a [__] tear down all right
Yankees up in with you he's open but the
homers the devil rays I think they're at
Serrano's open for four and then they
come home to Devil Rays I wish I'd go
this Wednesday day game right out the
gates but like I gotta go to [__]
Albany that day breaking news all right
going to Albany what's what opening day
for the Yankees is was this for
everybody right I think it's a second
what what is it enough okay so raise a
raise okay yeah there's a home opener
the home opener yeah it's fun
Sabo thank you so much brother great
meaning anytime bro
uh we got a hangout moment when I come
up there I'd love to come see all the
stuff you got there and always go to
vape exhale calm right yeah that's all
you need to do if you want to get set up
at this definitely works because I'm
stoned as [__] fight mommy
good luck thank you don't squeeze that
thing out before next week cuz we got to
have you
back on Tuesday because then you're
probably not going to be back yeah do it
for a little while right she's used to
if you could get us some video for
patreon that would be great from from
the delivery room tell I know we have to
share it with Danish no Neil did it go
that's fine therapy that's fine they're
gonna put that on patreon you guys say
you are too if we can get a GoPro in the
room can would you would you wear a
GoPro on each ankle get in like a 3d no
I don't think I could even see that
Jeff's not good I've never I've never
want I've never seen it really oh hell
no wait so would you have you thought
about what you'd rather have a cesarean
or a natural I really don't know they
both terrify me I'd just rather get it
cut out yeah you're right yeah and I
think I would too
oh I've thought of a good I think I told
you this I'll be talked about in the
patron but I thought I'll close on this
it's a great way to close I thought of a
good way to kill myself okay right oh
yeah well the other one that I had was
if you just put me in a bunch of chains
and then put me on a pier and then light
me on fire and then let me burn for a
solid 10 15 minutes you would be so dead
and then pushed me in the water and I
don't want to go quite that long to you
on the burning for 44 minutes yeah
that's about right I want to go a long
time because you definitely dead
Danforth for a minute you want to make
sure you drown though so yeah you gotta
go about push okay so like three minutes
and push me in the thing that was good
but now I got it the other way this
one's even better I just gonna get into
a body bag zip it up and just wait just
hard to death I don't know I just lay in
a body bag a way to die that's how they
killed a guy on Homeland last week they
put him in a body bag tied his arm dump
them in the water yeah yeah alive I want
to do that without the water I just want
you know first yeah of course first day
and a half your phone's dead now you
don't have any batteries
you unzip it and come out no wait wait
to die I have somebody else lip it up
that's a move so you can't zip it out
unzip it from the inside
exactly yeah no no that's a good idea
man if it's really it's it's a low
footprint you know low carbon footprint
that's right yeah you're exactly right
let's put that in the bag of bats just
go lay down like a card and open up that
thing later and just grow flowers out of
it exactly yeah just eat a bunch of our
sunflower seeds before you go in and
order [__] it if you're into weird stuff
don't [__] it don't please don't [__]
Mike Aaron Aaron is uh Aaron is Aaron
you're in the [__] oh that's right so
anyways guys love it thanks for
listening yes yes with Kobayashi being
one of Japan's finest exports and we
have Sabo in here as a fellow Japanese
person do you have any advice from the
nationality of the former hot dog eating
champion to a current hot dog taking
enthusiast like myself maybe Sam any
advice on how to get this done
I think wait how to train to eat more
hot dogs or how to get Saturday Ida Jam
one in your ass oh oh I think well I
would imagine it's like jam and a dildo
up your ass you got to lube it up and
just do it there you go
from a Japanese person to an American
all right you three jump suck it I love
you sorry Aaron I love you thanks for
everybody listening stop you mean to sam
idiots